[Musik]
[Applaus]
das niveau kann ich tatsächlich grad
nicht finden
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video auf ein
spiel im internet gefunden was play
heißt
es ist ein spiel das den titel trägt
eine anti windows auf deutschland setzt
dich ab überhaupt keine ahnung ich würde
sagen wir kriegen einfach mal auf
playboy und winfried von gogol richmond
oval office nothmann oder einem nord ein
cookie und dann ihr war der bbu
also ich würde sagen er den kombi
geklaut das heißt sie gehen weiterhin
direkt mit einem klick ins tief
[Musik]
eigentlich diesen text einmal gemacht
habe oder nicht aber wenn ich schon mal
gemacht habe dann kann ich mich auf
jeden fall verzichten erinnern
im gebiet also ich muss helfen was apple
also eher in die hand und
hey
dabei ich weiß nicht was das die rechts
darstellen soll wahrscheinlich einen
tisch dass ihr beim wagen
was ist wenn ich dann
ich weiß nicht wie weit ich seinen magen
hier füllen soll ich warte einfach mal
ab
[Musik]
aber wir machen weiter mit der frage ist
also wie kann man explodiert
und gerade in meinem video hier raus ich
weiß nicht was ich hier drücken soll
also ich bräuchte wahrscheinlich ein
spiel kann ich irgendwas umlegen
da kann ich was nehmen hier der button
das heißt ich bräuchte irgendwie nicht
den ich irgendwie
vol.at menschen bauen wenn ich nicht
oder der strecke trocknet also ich weiß
nicht wo ich darauf dass es hier oder im
bad irgendwie viel oder
und wie soll ich mit claudia iten ich
weiß nicht wo ich hier draufklicken toll
ich mache einfach mal hier so ein
bisschen und da und da und da und da und
darunter und da und da man nennt mich
übrigens auch den jungen picasso nächste
mission meine damen und herren what la
horde ok was bedeutet auf deutsch ich
habe das hier im internet gefunden
jetzt sucht die möbelhaus raus
das soll heute halten
wir haben
falsch beschrieben alter okay wenn ich
auf der feuerkuppe verbrennt er sicher
auch das feuer und dann sehen wir das
brand also bei der glühbirne macht
einfach nur sein mund auf hier hat er
irgendwie plätze im mund hierbei mehr
investieren hier passiert irgendwie auch
deine fresse luca fix rocket also ich
muss die rakete reparieren das hat mir
glaube ich auch schon mal ich weiß nicht
wie genau das ganze funktioniert und ob
ich das überhaupt richtig mache mit dem
club und dem hier und dann ja
ich habe sie gefragt oder wir platzieren
dass sie einfach auf seinem kopf kann
hier irgendwie an der seite den
blumentopf auch hier und die pizza
obendrauf und
die mache ich das click on the top of
the rock mit in den tod den roboter im
auftrag der tk unter teils wir müssen
einfach oben drauf legen jetzt packen
wir die ganzen sachen da rein
das legen hier das ding und ich habe gar
nicht geschieht niveau kann ich
tatsächlich gar nicht finden gesteht wir
wollen jemanden finden
das hat sich einfach mit der maus hier
durchgehend hier um hier um höhere mio
[Gelächter]
wir nehmen das hin und gern hier
und dieser bodytalk lässig
wir haben
trotz demnächst menschen anybody home
wenn wir einfach noch die klingel
drücken gehen wir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich klinge die ganz nah bei gott
wir haben einen typen war weg zwischen
haben wir denn schon leute die tanzen
also air berlin dann ihn und dann die
wir einfach nicht auf den dancefloor und
next mission es spiel der rheinländer am
11 das hat sie packen einfach hierhin
einmal hier dabei den absoluten nation
make-a-wish
jetzt habe ich mir was wünschen ich
wünsche mir dass ich am ersten sechsten
beim launch in lucka shop was bekomme
weil die sache werden wahrscheinlich
wieder vorneweg sachen also ich mach
jetzt die kerzen aus ich hoffe dass der
wunsch irgendwie in erfüllung gehe
drehte macht dass mein wunsch in
erfüllung geht ich gut noch extra alle
kersten autor hier noch 4 vorne und die
hier und bodyfit als setzte aufgabe deal
or no deal also wir das ding einfach mal
raus und dabei ist hier ja ja ja ja
2000 jahre später man sie doch jetzt
endlich diese beschissene ding hier raus
alter surya kommt ob ein schuljahr
kommen jetzt wieder die karriere
no
information
was bist du denn für ein knirps das
warte vom video meine damen und herren
ich möchte doch wieder heute nicht so
lange machen und nicht auf zehn minuten
schrecken weil ich keinen bock auf mit
folgen essen 35 grad kühl und ich leide
hier überhaupt nicht meine hose an wenn
euch das video gefallen bla bla leichter
lassen ich wirklich läuft auch mit dem
smiley 1 gewählt wer darauf klickt
blabla da oben mit dem neuen shop bietet
ersten sechs monaten anderen video cool